au printemps dernier craignant une
pénurie de nourriture on est nombreux à
avoir fait des razia au supermarché
quelques semaines plus tard cette
demande très forte s'est stabilisé mais
si vous ajoutez à cela la fermeture des
restaurants et de l'hôtellerie ça fait
beaucoup de bouleversements pour un
secteur qui est normalement réglé au
quart de tour
[Musique]
au printemps dernier par toupie les
entreprises et commerces ferment la
population se confinent les canadiens
mangent à la maison il avait l'habitude
de faire trois épiceries par semaine ils
n'en font plus qu'une seule un choc sur
les systèmes d'approvisionnement des
aliments si cette chaîne ne s'arrête
ben en aval de cette chaîne deuil des
procédés eux qui s'arrêtent pas les
animaux continuent de croître
les pôles continuent de faire d eux là
on est pris avec des stocks qu'on ne
peut pas gérer ni stocker ni entreposer
la production du lait les oeufs et de la
volaille qui repose sur un système qui
gère l'offre pour répondre à la demande
est déséquilibré
la demande a brusquement diminué
daley par exemple on s'attendait pas
devoir jeter du lait les oeufs c'est un
choc dans le lait après des ventes
record de début de pandémie de manière
subite
le pays est aux prises avec des surplus
de 12 millions de litres de lait des
industriels réussissent à fabriquer
d'importants volumes de fromages qu'on
congèle au québec des dons historique de
4 millions de litres sont faits aux
banques alimentaires
les éleveurs du québec met au
tarissement des vaches et réduisent
collectivement la production de 400
mille litres
malgré tout les producteurs canadiens
doivent se résigner à jeter 30 millions
de litres de lait
les américains au moins 100 millions de
litres on était dans l'urgence les gens
ont compris ça ça a été encore une fois
jeudi un réconfort pour les producteurs
puis un apaisement par rapport au stress
qu'ils ont vécu
la même chose du côté du poulet les
restaurants hôtels et cafétéria qui
prennent 40 % de tout le poulet du
québec
nash est pratiquement plus les
producteurs n'ont pas le choix ils
doivent réduire l'arrivée de poussins à
la ferme
ça se traduit au québec par une baisse
de quotas de 15% dans les provinces de
l'ouest de 7,5 pour cent résultat au
québec on enclenche l'euthanasie de
200000 poussins et l'élimination par les
couvoirs de deux millions deux
d'incubation destinés à devenir des
poulets dans les oeufs de consommation
après la rue en épicerie du début du
confinement et une augmentation des
ventes de 2 50%
c'est un revirement de situation les
ventes sont en chute
les éleveurs doivent donc ralentir la
production et réduire de 10 % la
production
il dirige aussi vers la consommation
animale 300 milles 12 n 2 et l'abattage
de plus de 300 mille poules pondeuses
destiné à être valorisés en bouillon et
empâté est devancé de deux semaines
les trois premiers mois de confinement
se traduisent par des pertes financières
importantes à la ferme
les éleveurs de volailles du canada les
estime à 110 millions de dollars
les producteurs de lait du québec
accueille aussi une diminution de leurs
revenus en avril pour les producteurs de
lait ça a été assez importante baisse de
10% des revenus mais c'est des revenus
qui récupèreront pas nécessairement
parce que si quête éperdue été perdu
mais alors que le secteur du lait des
oeufs et de la volaille réussissent à
stabiliser leur production
une autre situation dramatique surgi
dans le port d' important foyer de
contagion parmi les employés forcent la
fermeture complète d'un abattoir et la
cadence ralentie de moitié dans deux
autres usines
on s'est rendu compte assez rapidement
que il fallait que ça revienne à la
normale rapidement aussi parce que on
allait frapper un mur subitement des
ports près un abattage s'accumulent à la
ferme vers la fin de la période
d'élevage l'animal prend 5 à 6 kg par
semaine
c'est rendu des formule 1 ces animaux là
ça pousse très rapidement et dans des
périodes comme celle là on peut parler
ralentir un portrait à l'abattage ps
normalement 135 kilos mais les animaux
en attente frise 155 kg ils sont
entassés dans des parcs devenu trop
petit la ventilation est insuffisante le
bien être des animaux est en jeu le
producteur qui rend dans sa ferme qui
voit que depuis des années des années on
essaie d'instaurer le bien-être animal
qu'on met des normes qu'on conduit
comment faire pour justement être
vraiment sûr lasse vraiment impeccable
ben lui lui ça lui il ya deux fêtes qui
se trouve flamande année c'est sûr il
comprend pas là il se demande qu'est-ce
que il peut pas voir ces animaux
souffraient comme ça au plus fort de la
crise cent trente mille port sont
entassés dans les porcheries du québec
du jamais vu les éleveurs font face à un
dilemme grave et déchirant alors il
fallait absolument envisager on
l'envisagé et ça a été un à visage ma je
veux dire réfléchir en disant que si on
n'avait pas le choix
il aurait fallu peut-être peut-on gazier
depa et encore beaucoup d'incertitudes
ces jours là le président de l'union des
producteurs agricoles a cru que cette
fois ils risquaient de perdre l'appui de
la population
moi je crains hélas que des conséquences
qui auraient été durable comment la
commande publique aurait réagi si on
avait dû euthanasier départ ça aurait
été s'est jeté du lest une chose est
anase et de départ c'en est une eau mais
c'est pour les mêmes raisons
de concert avec la direction de la santé
publique les éleveurs et autres joueurs
de l'industrie se sont mis à l'oeuvre
pour élaborer des protocole de retour au
travail convenir des mesures sanitaires
en usine et dans le transport des
employés
le travail reprend et pour réduire
davantage les lots de porc en attente
des employés du zen volontaire au
travail et des jours supplémentaires
je contacte les employés des usines et
ya répondu présent quand il nous a aidés
à sortir de cette impasse sonne
puis lentement mais de manière certaine
la pandémie à amener le consommateur a
révisé ses achats d'aliments
l'idée fait son chemin la nourriture
produite au pays et à proximité a la
cote
maintenant faut miser sur l'engouement
des québécois pour les produits
québécois pis aller vers le positif
malgré cette situation là